[Music]
all right glad to be with you uh Ash
well Ash Wednesday which I don't know if
this is going up on Wednesday because we
have to pre-tape uh with my guest today
because he's he's busy he's run like
nine companies or something but he has a
new book uh choose your enemies wisely
business planning for the audacious few
and you can actually pre-order pre-order
it on Amazon um it's available December
5th and I've done his show a few times
and he's been around here Mr Patrick Bet
David how are you sir very good yeah
very good what is there some inside Lane
here that I know is there something that
like why so very good why very good
because you know no matter how crazy
things may be that you know not
everybody knows about at the end of the
day man if you're living in America if
you if you can go out there and you know
voice your opinion to the best of your
abilities live your life you're in uh
the arena competing you know getting
shots taken at you got you know allies
enemies it's exciting this is all
exciting to me you said things that
maybe people don't know I feel like you
like the inside Lane on things you're
like some things that maybe people don't
know in business that's a big thing
right like knowing something that
someone else doesn't know having a trick
I think it is I think you know surprise
is I'm a surprise guy you know it's
funny last night I'm in glendel at
rafy's Place having a dinner with my
friend Steph afo and afo says I don't
know how you do it I said what do you
mean he says I can't keep surprises the
other day I'm paying off my house for
paying off my daughter my sister's house
and I want to surprise her at the house
party I couldn't hold till the weekend I
have to tell her on the phone every was
like how can you hold so many surprises
you didn't tell us what you're doing
with the Yankees you're not like the my
dad is all about surprises I love
surprises yeah and an element of
competing in a Marketplace is surprise
and you know that no one's expecting
what to happen so that that's exciting
that's exciting yeah there's some people
who hate surprises like Johnny Boy
you've met him uh I mean if I come
around a corner he he not a fan of it no
he wets himself guess what you got to
surprise me if he's Happ
in a door I just like well I guess I'm
hiding behind the door now and I just
lean out he's it's like gullible people
yeah he's just Jumpy the best people in
the world are Goble people yeah yeah you
you can practice jokes on them pranks on
them they're the best I mean you can
clear out their savings account by
pretending to be a Nigerian prince you
know of course that's a felony though so
I don't they don't have the best didn't
a guy just do down and steal 8 billion
and he's going to jail for maybe 100
years or 10 years and his mother wrote a
paper from Stanford she was a Stanford
law professor the the uh responsibility
like you know we have to not pay that
much attention to responsibility what's
his name Sam something right Sam bankman
free oh Sam bankman free yeah yeah no he
didn't fake being a Nigerian prince no
he did a whole B it was his the FTX
Scandal yeah the FTX Scandal yeah no the
problem with the Internet is it's too
easy to sometimes you know there's a
generation gap um so I mean my my
grandmother you know rest in peace now
but um she used to have her home office
she would say this is this is where I do
my
forwarding I was like oh that's why I
get 15 emails from you like before this
you never watch walked up and physically
handed me a picture of Michelle Obama
what appears to be a penis like there
was a level of propriety that you didn't
grandma gave you pictures of Michelle
Obama which well she's like you know
she's a man you know that kind of thing
and you're like she it's a forward but
she treated it like a job and because
they think like this is all news and so
it does happen on both sides with the
with the fake news uh but uh so you've
been you've been around for a long time
people do you actually is it nine
companies that you run nine companies
right now yeah how does that happen I
mean how do you run nine companies like
because I want to get to your whole your
your origin story I guess if you will
but that is something that right away on
its face just you know sounds shocking
to people so so I don't recommend it by
the way it's not something I recommend
when I say nine companies you don't
start like that for me originally well
you know when I went into Financial
Services with Morgan stany Dean Witter I
left I went to Trans America World
Financial I was with them for S and A2
years and then at the tail end of it I
watched Jerry Maguire literally after
Jerry McGuire I write a 16 page you know
what we ought to do to take this company
to the next level with nine ideas that I
have and I emailed it nobody responds
back then I email it to the co of Aon uh
and he responds back and he sends it to
a guy named Jack then Jack calls
everybody that didn't respond to me to
fly out to Orange County have a meeting
with me for seven eight hours and I
proposed everything and then and then
nothing happened so I went back and I
said okay no problem if that's the case
if you don't value these ideas maybe I
go do with my myself and I had a meeting
in uh Atlanta with them in a room with
15 people around the room I wish that
was recorded by the way all the lawyers
are there presidents everybody I said
I'm here to make one of four decisions
I'm either going to stay here be the CEO
I'm either going to sell my business I'm
either going to go to another industry
or I'm going to resign and go start my
own company they said you'll never
resign and start your own company I said
you don't think I'll do it says Nope for
the last 20 years people like you come
here threatening to leave they don't
they want a check we give them a check
and then they never leave and had never
plans of leaving anyway so we don't
believe you I said okay fair enough I
think that's a fair assessment so um a
month later I had an event in uh JW
Marriot Palm Springs called saving
America doing the impossible this is 09
and I'm dressed as George Washington you
can actually find this picture it's
pretty funny my wife is dressed as Lady
Lady Liberty this is three weeks after
we got married 40 foot Mount Rushmore 4
500 people in the audience the events
called saving America doing the
impossible I bring uh Larry Green field
from Claremont Institute to talk about
the history of capitalism I bring Dudley
Rutherford to talk about the star
spangle banner and Ando we launched that
three months later I resigned I start
own
company PHP agency with 66 agents
insurance company and we grew that from
66 to 45,000 agents we sold it last June
to Integrity Marketing Group that's
Dallas based and Silver Lake nice exit
it was exciting it was great but then
throughout that process I'm producing
content with value tainment purely for
entrepreneurs and business owners and
the entire time you know my audiences
small business owners salespeople
executive SE sues Founders and my
content is how to raise money you want
to raise $10 million how here's how I
did it here's 10 things to look out for
you want to sign a lease have a half a
million square feet of office P office
space Nationwide these are the 20 things
you should be looking out for this is
what that guy's thinking this is what
you're thinking here's how to negotiate
with them boom you want to fire somebody
somebody hire SE sues so that was my
content for 5 six seven years and then
my interest became I get a call from
somebody from Peru a Booker saying you
know I heard you on krla with Bill
Martinez and you know I think you need
to interview this guy named Michael
Frances I said the mobster he says yes I
says I'm a business content guy he says
I think it'll blow up I said I'm not
going to do that it's that's not content
for me year and a half later we do the
interview gets 20 million views then I
interviewed Sammy D Gano all these
Mobsters Phil leonetti they all started
calling me because I always watched
Godfather was an always interesting
power play you know what they did and
then we did bunch of CIA interviews you
know business interviews bodybuilding
interviews and then we found different
niches then my interest was always
politics cuz I started seeing the more
money you make how they abuse you matter
of fact today I was looking at a data
crazy data from tax Foundation do you
know what percent of the income tax that
the government gets the top 1% pays that
the top 1% the top 1% I think they pay
somewhere around 60 something per but
I've seen as high as 80 it's like 20%
pays 80% in taxes 20% pays 80% but this
is specifically 1% 1% Crowder pays
42.3% but do you know what the bottom
50% pays in tax is 2.3% you well 47% of
Americans right that's what got Romney
in trouble or maybe it was 43 was either
43 or 47 don't pay any federal income
tax yeah and he said it in a way that
was you know obviously wildly unpopular
but it was a fact that whole door was
open when he made that comment yeah said
binders full of women where he really
screwed up was he said he put the dog on
the roof of his car that's where that's
when that was a bridge too far people
like well not not this but you know out
of your mind this is it you cannot
cannot you're not ready to be president
well no one likes him anyway and then I
started noticing how when we're
appointed in 49 states how I'm in Texas
but I'm still paying taxes in California
and I'm paying taxes in all these other
states because insurance when you saw
I'm like okay this is interesting what's
going on more and more and more I got
into it I said I want to talk about the
stuff so then we separated by tment with
pbd podcast we started that and AO and
now the nine companies one is a
consulting firm growing very rapidly B
de Consulting then we have a product
development site with Man app and Vault
drink then we have the shows then we
have the cigar Louch then we have the
comedy club let me ask you why do that
in other words people will ask because
I've been around some people who are
incredibly wealthy right oh it's still I
thought you might have to relight it uh
incredibly wealthy and then they often
still and I don't think this is the case
with you
but they still want more notoriety or
fame in other words you don't need to
have a podcast right to to make a living
um it's not like you were drawn to it
because you wanted the big checks um why
do it it makes sense to have a smaller
podcast on investing a lot of people do
that right for their investors or their
money managers Etc um what made you say
Okay I want to take this risk and that's
a lot of work to do the podcast or the
company yeah well the the the more
entertainment Centric companies as
opposed to Insurance investment oh
there's no question that's a whole
different story you know my my pastor of
mine Dudley Rutherford who uh uh married
my wife and I one time he gave a talk
saying there's seven pillars uh in
America to climb it was military family
church entertainment media and he's kind
of listen Sports all these things he's
list and I says the most powerful one to
climb is Media but it's also the hardest
one and I always thought about this he
said this in 2009 2010 I'm like media is
the hardest one but the most powerful
one why is that and he start noticing
what's going on with media and what the
messaging is who's giving it who's
telling it what they're doing the level
of Trust in Media today how it's
theclinic it's the lowest it's ever been
the numbers came up last week and the
trust in US government and media is at
the lowest it started off being very
high right pre JFK we're at 70 72% now
we're at 27% you don't trust mainstream
media when you're watching it and if you
think about these guys they got a
teleprompter there somebody's writing
for them these comedians that are doing
what they're doing the chemel the
fallons fallons actually pretty talented
but you're watching all these guys
they're reading a teleprompter when
writers uh uh went on that strike these
guys couldn't do anything for 4 weeks
and they came out with a
podcast and you're watching you know
mainstream media with MSNBC with Fox
Murdoch on his way out you don't know
what his sons are going to do Ted Turner
at the end of his book when he writes
the book you know he claims how
disappointed he is with what the product
of CNN turned into if you've never
watched the read the book Ted highly
recommend it and at the end there's an
interview being done with him that that
this was not the product I produce CNN
the idea wasn't to be this right so I I
saw this the guy who created the WCW
with Eric bishof so it must be really
bad who yeah if he's disappointed in CNN
I mean he said some he said some
misfires so that says a lot oh yeah he
did no doubt about it but he's a
heavyweight in media the last 50 years
almost revolutionized the game so even
he's not happy with what's going on with
Cenna so I saw an opening and I said
okay uh I don't like bullies I don't
like gamification I was a kid that was
caught in between a a mom and a dad
mom's side family they were Communists
dad side's family they were imperialist
they kept fighting every day they
divorced twice in 20 years each other by
the way they got married my sister's
born they got divorced family pressured
for them to get remarried because in
Middle Eastern you know culture you
don't get divorc they got remarried then
I'm born then they got divorced okay
every night was a fight over two
concepts that side said poor people are
lazy mom's side rich people are greedy
who's right I don't have a clue I love
both of them so I'm going through this
process to see is Mom right or rich
people truly GRE greedy is that right
are poor people really lazy maybe
they're both right maybe they're both
wrong let me kind of figure it out for
myself and then today from having been
in business and watching people that the
more you did for this guy the more he
hated you later on because you stopped
doing for him he was expecting you to do
forever you create the less you did for
this guy and he independently you gave
him a little bit he won he was more
grateful you had a better relationship
with them so that Dynamic happening over
and over and over again and one time
I'll never forget one of our guys in our
company who was a
socialist and he hated capitalism and
all this stuff but he wanted to sell
insurance because he wanted to make more
money every time he would send me a book
about the Dark Side of capitalism the
history of capitalism slavery all the
stuff he would send me one day he got a
$20,000 bonus and I called him up I said
'hey man I just want to congratulate you
on your $20,000 bonus but I got a great
idea he says what's that I said did you
do this by yourself or was was this the
help of you and your 50 guys he says no
this is the help of me and my 50 guys I
said so here's what I wanted to do I
think I'm sure you're going to be in on
this one yeah I'm thinking about taking
his $20,000 that you earned but you
really didn't cuz it's you and the 50
guys giving your 50 guys $400 a pop and
telling them that because you're so
Noble you want to give these guys the
$400 he says that's not fair I said wait
I'm sorry he says that's not fair yeah I
said you're right it's not fair cuz you
earned it right he says I got you see
those moments as a did he have an
Ebenezer Scrooge moment did he turn from
his ways or he he still okay he actually
did he actually I wouldn't say he's but
at least he came Center so so business
brought him from far left to left to
Center where he's sitting there saying
no yeah there are people that are going
to do more than others and they earned
the right to get paid more than others
yeah it's a it's one of those things
it's a it's a they always say it's
beautiful in theory until they meet yeah
the lighters right there uh until they
actually meet that theory in practice
and you cannot force someone to do work
if they don't want to and of course
they're probably helped you know of
course people deserve a living wage um
but I have found you know in my
experience I was raised in Quebec which
is basically a socialist Province um for
for lack of a better word it's like its
own country a lot of people will tell
you this Quebec in relation to the rest
of Canada so I didn't really know many
wealthy uh people at all you know you'd
be like oh look at that that's that's Mr
Hines he makes $100,000 you know like a
big deal
um and in my experience uh the most
generous people who I've met in my life
and I know this isn't always the rule
have been people who've been very
successful and very wealthy and some of
the most selfish people that I've met
and entitled have been poor people where
I did realize just being around these
folks and I was very fortunate I
realized okay it just amplifies
character money amplifies character and
if you're if you're a bad character
it'll amplify it so we as Christians and
as conservatives are beholden to try and
perform ethically um are like I always
say this is with what I do this is
business but it's not just business if
it was just business there would be ways
to squeeze more money out um we have to
behave ethically but I I have met a lot
of wealthy people who have been
incredibly generous where I probably
wouldn't be here today if they didn't
help you know bring me on to consult
early on with social media you know when
I had a small YouTube channel um and
these weren't donors these were people
who said hey I could use someone like
you to to to help me kind of learn how
to do these things in Market but before
we get to that I I think because we're
getting into business a lot of people
don't realize you know they would think
you're someone who went to you know
Stanford or some expensive School of
Business you know ivy league you're a
guy you were you're originally from Iran
um and English is you learn English
later right Fifth Fifth language your
fifth language right so Armenian first
Assyrian second that's my dad's Aramaic
then fary 3rd I lived in Iran 10 years
Germany fourth I lived in Germany for 2
years year and a half then English fifth
right so Aramaic so was The Passion of
the Christ anti-semitic because you know
what they were
saying did did it say the stuff they
said that it said by the way I could
understand everything that were saying
in Passion of Christ cuz you can
understand
were they just saying like watermelon
peas and carrots like extra dialogue
he's antiemetic funny the other day
watching a video from Netanyahu from
2001 in a small group setting where he's
talking about don't worry about
Americans we can convince 80% of them
they're on our side if we want to do
anything we want to do and we're is this
really what he's saying we got to kind
of find out because we're just reading
the right you know captions but yeah no
so five so nine businesses five
languages very very uh very quick way to
Humble brag but I I'll allow it um and
you were then you were obviously you
moved to Germany then the United States
you were in the military for a period of
time then went into business but a big
part you know we were uh out at your I
guess compound in Florida you told me
kind of your testimony too about
becoming a Christian that you were an
atheist and um it it was almost George
Foreman esque as far as your conversion
it wasn't like ah I guess I'll be a
Christian um tell me kind of what that's
because I think a lot of people may not
necessarily know that uh about you they
Pro they know you're a Christian um they
know that you're more conservative in
your values but they may not know what
that transition was was like yeah so
when you live in Iran you have a hard
time believing in God I I would always
get kicked out of Bible study my my dad
and mom would come in and say why can't
you just sit there I'm like I I I don't
believe this stuff I said why is it were
your parents Christians they're
Christians both of them I said why is it
that if we're getting bombed in Iran the
parks I'm going to that building we used
to go to the whistling sound T Al
attention attention the sign of red
means that planes have crossed the
border and boom so all of these thoughts
that stay with you yeah I don't believe
in God we go to Germany my parents get a
divorce I even get less you know desire
to want to have any kind of closeness to
God 12 to 18 zero Church zero anything
you couldn't get I was a guy at church
making fun of the pastor and I go to the
Army I'm in boot camp and in boot camp
and a AIT uh I had one the higher uh PT
scor so they gave me and a few other
guys the opportunity to go spend time at
this one camp for two days and this guy
had the swing from trees into the lake
and pool table I'm like this is great to
get away from all the stuff we're doing
but with one caveat every night we had
to listen to him do Bible study and by
the way even then that's 97 the military
20 26 years ago so I was sitting the
back and I would play with the blyard
balls in the back I would just kind of
do my thing and he's doing his thing and
then at the end of it he comes up to me
says hey son my parents gave me uh this
Bible as a gift in 1974 December 24th of
1974 I'll never forget I have it till
today he says I think you need this more
than I need this I said I'm telling you
I'm the wrong guy to give this to so
waste this is your parents it's a gift
he says son I've been watching you I've
been listening to you you need this just
take it for me trust me so I finally
take it I leave why is this guy giving
it to me I don't read the
Bible but I sit there started praying
three times a day my prayer started like
this God I don't believe in you I think
it's fake I think it's for weak people
but if you're out there great I want to
know something but if not I'm talking
anyways here's what's on my mind today
okay and and I would kind of do my thing
fast forward with that I get out of the
army and I'm the one that's going around
and you know get involved in World
Financial the people I was working with
they were Mormons and scientologists so
scientologists are trying to get me to
become Scientologist and I'm going to
their facility in Hollywood and then
Mormons I'm reading all this stuff about
Gordon B hinley the virtues all this
stuff it was actually great things and I
watched Mormons how United they were one
day I'm in the office this girl comes
and she says I just watched the greatest
movie of all time this is probably going
to win an awesome
I'm like no yeah what's the movie's
name Napoleon Dynamite I said Napoleon
Dynamite yeah well I do think it got
like MTV Movie Awards I went and watched
the movie the entire time I am annoyed
really because she told me this is going
to win an Oscar I come back I said this
was one of the worst movies I've ever
seen in my life what was this all about
and eventually one of the guys that
wasn't a Mormon say the actor is a
Mormon so they support each other I'm
like okay I respect
that but I can understand if you went in
you you were expecting the prestige
where it's like there's going to be some
big moment yeah so that's the worst so
anyways but then I respected the fact
that Mormons were United and then so at
this point I'm like you know what
whatever uh I start going on a journey
and I start going to everything I can I
knew Muslim because I grew up in Iran so
I understood Hezbollah Muslim their
beliefs Prophet Muhammad I've gone
through that route I started looking at
Scientology elron hubber Dione you know
what he believes in what their ideas are
I started looking at your seating levels
I went through a lot of it by the way I
the assist and all these things you got
to do very interesting it reminded me of
a Freemason model like you can go up and
move up and all this stuff plus a few
other ancillary stuff yeah anyways and
then eventually uh I became a Christian
at 25 years old January 21st or some
date like that in ' 04 I become a
Christian I go to this church of
Shepherd of the Hills 27 churches I went
to one church I went to was called the
Los Angeles Church of Christ this guy
sits me down guy named Edward never
forget I'm sitting there with my
girlfriend who's an actress in Hollywood
and beautiful girl and uh he say so
when's the last time you guys had sex I
said right before this meeting he says
you can't come to church if you're not
going to commit to you have to drop sex
I said brother we're good yeah are we
good and I walked away did he shake your
hand or did he actually wash well I mean
he shook my hand whether he believed
what I did with my hand that's up to him
that's his risk not my risk exactly all
right so I walked away and I'm like no
not going to happen anyways this scroll
and I who we about we're about to get
married I love her I want to marry her
this this the same one you were sleeping
with absolutely and I say listen I want
to test something with you and I because
if we're going to get married I want to
know if this is more than sex she says
okay what do you want to do I said I
want to go one month no sex she said
you're serious I said yeah says do you
have someone else on your life I said no
I just want to know what we're going to
do on a Friday night when we're in the
Expedition without having sex and she
says you're sure about this I said yes
great first night Friday we're going out
by the way kind of undale it like it
makes it easier to say yeah one month no
sex in the Expedition you weren't
necessarily Romancing the situation
listen yeah when you're broke Expedition
is a bedroom that's true it is yes it's
a full three best part is when the
police puts the lights on you it's like
stop get out of here in the steam it's
like oh we're out of here thank you so
much officer appreciate you for not
every time you hear a siren you get
flushed that's bad conditioning but okay
so anyway so she thinks I'm weird we go
to church she's uncomfortable and then
Billy Graham comes to Pasadena and he
giv a talk in November of 2003 I go to
every single one of his services this is
after her uh except for Saturday I
missed the service I went to 3 them not
on the one on Saturday cuz I had
training but so we go for a month
doesn't happen afterwards I say it's not
going to work out she found another guy
we had a bad breakup but we're civil
we're good we move on and and I'm like
you know what I don't know what I'm
doing here So eventually I get baptized
I become a Christian and then I start
doing Bible study uh Friday night night
at pasaz Pasadena from 6:00 p.m. to 2:
in the morning every other Friday night
we're doing Bible study from 6: to 2: 2
a.m. and we're talking on philosophy
debate all this stuff eventually the
crazy thing most people won't even
believe this if I say this I was the guy
in Old Pasadena in front of nightclubs
at 1:00 in the morning holding a John
316 sign at 25 years old that was me so
I just got on fire I went 17 months I
said I'm not touching any sex nothing
and that was my thing cuz I was in Vegas
all the I was very good guy to party
with six days a week I was that guy So
eventually I changed my habits and uh
that's very typical of Iranians if
they're not Muslim it's like either
they're Muslim or they just love to
party and like when I went to your house
I was not surprised at the amount of
marble but that was it and then
eventually uh one of the nights that
maybe it's the story you want to know is
my girl and I uh were at Universal
Studio CityWalk she'll remember this
vividly we're in the car we're having a
big fight I don't have any money I feel
like I'm like dude I can't have
$449,000 and I can't even afford to pay
n bucks for movies for this girl I felt
like I was just I was not a man at that
my dad would always say when men don't
have money they're not good for society
so you have to be able to contribute to
have your manliness we're in the car we
get into big fight and then we break it
off and she leaves I'm in the car
Expedition this is 1:30 in the morning
got this point we finished the movie and
I said God I haven't spoken to my mom
for 5 years but if if you exist I would
love to talk to my mom 30 seconds later
my next ta I get a call from a block
number brother this is like a I've told
the story it's a very weird moment in my
scariest moment for me I don't want to
answer the phone and it's one of those
next tells well you know the the flip
phones yeah and I flip it and it's my
mom crying so why are you crying she
says I got the feeling you were in pain
how'd you get this number she says you
know I just got it 6 months ago I said
but do you know what I'm going going
through right now what are you going I
said no nothing but I don't know how to
talk to her I hang up the phone I sat in
that car that night top of the hills
chills all over my body I'm like oh my
God either this is ironic or this is
real but the level of coincidence is a
little too real I could have chosen to
say it's ironic I chose to believe it
was God and he has my back and he's had
my back from day one that level of
confidence I got from that moment
that somebody was watching me and had my
back is the reason why I am where I'm at
today I make my decisions purely knowing
he has my back and if you ask me what's
one of my biggest
fears one of my biggest fears in my life
is losing his favor I can't tell you how
much that scares the hell out of me
because to me in life when you get a
person that has your back and they have
your back like you've seen endless times
they've had your back you take that for
granted and you lose it you're a fool so
you've had my back you've given me this
life the four kids my wife my dad now
living with me my biggest fear at the
time when I was not a Christian was my
kids never meeting my dad cuz I never
met his dad my grandpa they are best
friends with him now they love him my
son Place violent with him my 2-year-old
daughter's best friend is my dad where
they're together all the time and now
she goes to school she was going 5 days
we took her out 2 days so she can be
around my dad all the time and my nanny
who's been such an amazing woman in our
lives for 14 years her mom is 85 years
old she was worried about her mom so she
wanted to retire go to Mexico I said
bring your mom with us she lives with us
it we got a nice place in the house and
man I'm the luckiest man alive but
because I have that favor so imagine you
have that kind of an Untouchable favor
you want to compromise that favor so so
it's such a it's it's a unique that's
that's your biggest fear oh I can't even
describe it to you mine's bull sharks
yeah yours is bull sharks swim in fresh
water I respect it but no I actually
very similar fear but you had the
Expedition detailed right after all that
not all the time not all the time all
right not all the um mine is not
necessarily uh losing favor but I do
understand that you know I do have um
one thing I'm very fortunate I can
certainly relate with that you know
you've met Johnny Boy and and Gerald
these are you I've been friends with
Johnny Boy since was 12 years old and I
make sure to never take that for granted
uh and Gerald now for 16 17 years I have
lifelong friends but certainly standing
You Know Before the Throne of God um and
uh at some point he's going to list your
talents right we've all read the parable
of the talents I know it's a different
term talent but that's what the word
that's used and uh him showing a list of
what I could have done with it that I
was expected to do with it and I didn't
and throw it away and that's what keeps
me doing it where there look this is not
the I don't run nine companies but this
is you know there were there were years
I was working 80 hours for years and I
just thought you know I never want to
throw it away once there was momentum I
thought well it is my duty to do as much
with this as I can this a very hard
business as well yeah but I understand
that it's you do if you if you believe
that there's accountability too um and
some of it comes from Fear some of it
comes from love but I want to say this
as well to me a part of it is not
perfection to me it's like I don't set
the standard of myself of walking on
water and having that I'm not that guy
no because if you you know when I got
married uh uh at the end of the wedding
uh we're in glendel California and I get
up and I give uh we got 500 people at
the winning and I said hey guys on one
side is all the greeneyed blue-eyed
people on the other side is all the
hairy people cuz it's Middle Easterns
and Caucasians cuz my wife is from Texas
so and by the one of the best jokes uh
one of my friends told me one of my
groomsman who was so hammered he was so
hammered it's not even funny he gets up
he says uh so look I can tell none of
you guys want to dance because you're
concerned whether this marriage is going
to work out or not I am also concerned
because he's from Iran and she's from
Texas why would this marriage work he
says but I finally figured out they have
a very good chance of this thing working
out it's because of two things um she's
Texas he's Iran they have two things in
common they both love weapons of mass
destruction and oil this is a perfect
marriage everyone laughs gets up they
start dancing but I said something I
said listen two things I want you to
know and I'm talking to my family and
friends number one if you ask my wife
one time if she's pregnant or not you
will never see us again don't put the
pressure on my wife being pregnant or
not and saying does your body work does
his body work it's none of your business
so don't ask number two I don't know how
long we're going to be married but I
believe we can be married at least one
year and we're going to take it one year
at a time that's it I don't have the
pressure of no matter what because what
if she all of a sudden changes right
what if all of a sudden life changes
that pressure or something by the way
this is controversial every time I say
this in my Christian Community how could
you say that didn't you your vows and
all this other stuff no they're missing
the point no no to me the point is the
outside pressure that people want to
impose on you to live this perfect life
that a you
know perfect what do you call it uh uh
uh what is that thing that uh microscope
that just kind of watching every single
moveie you make I'm not living for you
man I'm living for God I'm living for my
family I'm living for div Vision I'm
living for what's been put on my heart
at the same time if we can find people
that are good running mates even go at
it one thing in a book that we talk
about you said you know Gerald and you
said John Johnny boy or so one of the
things we talk about in the book Because
as as a person who runs a company and
you run a business you eventually want
to have a circle of people you trust M
so one day one of my guys that wants to
be in that inner circle I'm picking him
up from jail it's 4:00 a.m. in the
morning I'm in a parking lot maybe not
the best community best neighborhood
park parked outside okay I go in in a
suit they think I'm his lawyer I'm not
his lawyer this guy's been in my life
for 14 years I've known him since he was
14 years uh 18 years old he comes out I
get him out of jail he's sitting in the
car we're driving I have nothing to tell
him he says how come you're not telling
me anything I said brother I have
nothing to tell you he says Pat I need
to hear something I said nothing if you
haven't heard anything I've told you
what do you think's gonna you gonna
listen to me now he says I'm telling you
I need to hear something from you I said
I'll tell you two things one you lack
gratitude two you lack perspective
you're not grateful for the people God's
put in your life and you lack
perspective to realize you can change I
can't do that for you but one thing I
can tell you there's zero chance you can
be in my life if you drink liquor moving
forward you can't you can't be in the
Inner Circle you can be my life you can
be somebody that's do this but you want
to be here it's not going to happen so
in the book I mapped out six things you
got to look at and then score the people
in your life uh to be your running mates
because anyone that ever never did
anything big look at musk if you look at
musk with who he trusts why does he
always lean on David Sachs that's one of
the guys he trust if you look at any
athlete any coach any businessman any
Pastor any content creator there's
people behind closed doors that you can
go to to say what do you think and you
can p put your feet up the documentary
about Tiger Woods one of the best things
about Tiger Woods documentary was when
they they said how Michael Jordan said
how tiger and him started hanging out
together
and he says tiger would come and he
would be relaxed with me why because
goats understand goats MH I understand
the pressures of being a goat he's
saying that Michael he doesn't say goat
but he says I understand the pressure
comes with being who he is but you need
people around you that you can relax
with you know if you want to do
something big specifically you need to
choose your running mat so as you get
bigger choosing running mates becomes a
very important thing and obviously if
you're explaining about Gerald and
Johnny boy yeah you need guys like that
yeah no it's it's definitely it's it's
pivotal um especially in an industry
like this you know where um look we also
live in a world where where loyalty
doesn't mean a whole lot and the thing
is I think sometimes people get it wrong
when they talk about loyalty that
doesn't mean yes men I actually had a um
someone explain it to me this way she's
a a clinical psychologist she said yeah
men uh or women attempting to do great
things didn't use the term goat said
they don't need Yes Men but they need
cornermen so they need someone where you
know these guys are out there they're
taking the blows they're they're in the
fight they go back into the corner and
if you're winning if you're doing well
you need a talk great keep doing what
you're doing maybe some advice some
improvements if you're not they need to
put the ice on the swelling on the eye
fix put some Vaseline in the cut try and
get you back out there because not
everyone can be out there actually
taking the blows not everyone there's
one prize fighter but it takes a whole
team and a yes man is useless and we saw
that for example that's what happened
with Mike Tyson perfect example with
Buster Douglas that night they forgot to
bring the Nell I don't know if you know
that story they had a surgical glove and
they were putting ice in it and trying
to put it on his eye they didn't bring a
basic nwell you know the steel that you
haven't bought yet they they didn't
bring it because at that point he just
had an Entourage of Yes Men custom a you
know wasn't around anymore these people
kind of got their hooks in and it was
the most embarrassing Corner job they
spilled ice everywhere um and when she
said that it clicked because even by the
way if you're the prize fighter in your
company you know at some point you're
going to be old older and you're going
to be the corner man for your son you
know we all transition in those in in
those positions and uh it made a lot of
sense because I think sometimes people
think loyalty or someone who values
loyalty wants a Yes Man and they don't
they need a corner man everyone
sometimes you know look you run nine
companies I'm on a
bet outside of the people who you
discuss like who you trust who you know
really closely you probably don't get a
lot of pats on the back you have to give
pats on the back right you have to do
that as a leader of your company because
those people have to feel appreciated
I'm Welling I bet you don't get that as
much so you need some people around you
who kind of give you that feedback so
that at least you know what you're doing
is either correct or it's not and some
you know you're not shooting in the dark
there's also part of it where you know
uh I'm talking to Brad Lee the other day
Bradley's a good content creator very
good content creator out of Vegas and
I'm talking to him that as you're moving
up you have to be very careful to filter
out flattery right because flattery is
actually a terrible thing you know the
whole concept with the Marcus aelius
who's sitting there having a slave right
behind him telling them you know you're
not as important as you think you are
you're not as important as you think you
are you need people like that in your
life but no I agree I agree the people
to process with the insurance company uh
uh the person that I S I want to say
Marcus have you you've read meditations
I'm sure of course Marcus Urus is
fascinating to me too um because he's a
an ex to me stoicism is uh almost
practiced Christianity in the absence of
Grace it's about doing the right thing
not for Earthly riches right but for
doing the right thing sake but at the
end of the day you do it and you die and
we obviously believe in Eternal
salvation and there's a purpose as to
why you're also doing the right thing
why you're following that prescription
but Marcus Aurelius was certainly by all
accounts a good man and then became
addicted to opiates uh he didn't know
you know he said you mustn't consume
strong drink like he really believed in
being disciplined but that's bad advice
someone going here's a tincture it'll
make you feel better and you read his
later writings you see this is a guy who
didn't know he became addicted to
painkiller so great people actively
doing good things can still make
mistakes he's a one of my most to me
fascinating uh figures in history and
well I mean wonderful study yeah so so
that takes it to a whole different angle
as well you know where uh almost anybody
that does anything very big that we
admire they're complicated people people
they're not simple boom in a box well
they're not like that they're
complicated people that they it takes a
complicated person to tolerate the
amount of pain and responsibility that
comes with it knowing the the credit
you're probably going to get is going to
happen when you die not when you're
alive are you okay with that can you
imagine like hey the biggest credit
you're ever going to get is when you die
and what kind of recognition is that
well that's the best kind of recognition
you want to do that well no I want the
Credit Now doesn't work that way those
guys you know comes afterwards criticism
when you're alive credit after you die
do you think that's why you're able to
also get these interviews with these
very high-profile people because you're
empathetic to that you're empathetic to
people big absolutely because look in
our insurance I'll never forget one
thing that happened in 2013 one of our
guys did something and he was a face of
the company and he went through an ugly
divorce very ugly public we're in
Tuscany Italy and in Tuscan Italy moment
happens where wife comes out she hears
news she's crying this is an trip and
I'm like you got to be kidding me he all
this money we spent this is going to oh
my God so I said okay maybe there's a
reason why this is happening when that
happened people behind CLA I can't
believe he's going through this I can't
believe he's going through that I can't
believe he's going through this and I
told everybody said guys here's all I'll
tell you okay be very careful very
careful judging with somebody else's
personal life that you don't have all
the Intel to be very very careful cuz
when it comes back and happens to you
trust me you're going to want Grace no
you don't just just be careful boom 2
years later it happened to other people
in different ways and then I sat down
with a couple of those guys said now you
see what I was talking to you about by
the way they're still all around the
company we have an incredible
relationship they're doing very well for
themselves but my parents my upbringing
my own flaws my own big fall in my early
20s massive fall I had I'm a 21y old guy
giving speeches on Yachts for a
billionaire named mcnalty who has a $65
million house and I'm the guy that's
giving this and I'm making money and I'm
like the Superstar coming up you know
poster child type of a guy and then all
of a sudden boom crash crash crash crash
and I'm like dude I'm going back in the
Army I was about to join back in the
Army in just through 20 years I would
have retired three years ago four years
ago got my benefits I was in the Army
two and a half years Hunter first
Airborne I love the Army great go back
and do that you'll be a sar major worst
case first sergeant you're going to have
a good life you'll go to DLI you go to
all these other things you know you
speak these languages you can go go to
Special Forces 18 Delta all these things
and then know and then I I had Grace I
stuck around I went so then later on in
my life yeah I think interviewing people
that uh uh will come with me and they'll
feel safe talking to us what am I
judging you for man no one's perfect we
all have our ini isales let's just talk
we could have a discourse and ideas like
chomo and I are friends right now I
can't believe you know if you would have
told me this like Chris chomo and I are
having talks and laughing I'm in Sag
Harbor having lunch with them then I go
to his house with his boys they take us
to the airport sitting there he's
FaceTiming me with Robert Downey Jr
saying hey I watched the podcast I'm
like Robert say hey Dylan Tio come here
take a look who this says oh my God Iron
Man is alive he's not dead cuz their
reaction is different oh my God they're
getting emotional like cuz kids don't
know anything when these guys watched
them die they were actually emotional so
I said no I need to Circle back that
might be bad
parenting Santa Claus is alive and
they're 24 years old he's and he's not
Tim Allen uh well I want to pretty soon
we have to to go to Mud Club here but I
I want did you always mean to go when
you were in the the Army was it always
part of a plan to go into business was
that your plan no not at all I wanted to
be bodybuilder my plan was to be Arnold
the old Arnold not the new Arnold my
plan was to be Arnold my plan was to go
no one wants to be 75 Arnold no not the
old Arnold what I mean by the screw your
freedom that's not the Arnold I admire I
admire the Arnold that came here won Mr
Olympia became star mared to Kennedy
became a governor that guy may have one
of the greatest American Dream stories
of all time minus the comments you made
about screw your freedom I wanted to be
that guy also screwing Menor out of the
uh 81 Olympia I believe but that's a
conversation for it's an interesting one
he probably doesn't like that but that's
a different weer was on his side weer
loved him you know so had to do it there
was a there was I mean there's a lot of
politics bodying but uh so you wanted to
be a bodybuilder so how do you go from
that to okay nine businesses I mean
because that's that's at some point
something must have clicked did you just
realize I'm good at this well well no
I'm good at sales I'm I'm a I'm a good
sale I was selling when I was in Germany
you know Super Nintendo comes out and I
can't afford to buy the Super Mario
Brothers to and I have to find a way to
make money I go to a local swimming pool
in Airline again with my girlfriend
Katarina staf and we go and we say hey
what can I do to make some money here
say well you know can you collect this
beer bottles cuz Germans are famous for
drinking so I started collecting only
they famous for historically but that's
right forgive me there's a lot of things
they're famous for and they're also
tough to sell they're very skeptical
people yes we've heard this okay you
know you're not going to fool
me they're the worst crowds for comedy
too like mm right we get to laugh you
can make them laugh you're good that's a
good point but no I would say you know
that's the first time I made money on my
own I'm like okay if I can make this
kind of money at 11 years old and go to
Cowal and buy Super Mario Brothers and
be the only kid that's got that at a
refugee camp and I'm the coolest kid
here because of it freaking awesome I
can make money so that's kind of kid in
a refugee camp that's so sad listen when
you have a Super Nintendo picturing all
the other refug like oh he's in
cool he has Yi's Island I mean I don't
know they could be white no they were
from Yugoslavia Albania you know Czech
polish Afghanistan everywhere so anyways
so okay so you found that out but then
you went in the Army after that so was
in the back of your mind so then I I
meet a girl named Jean verier who's
working on Morgan Stanley Dean where we
start dating I start I'm a numbers guy
love numbers I'm like wait a minute how
can I work I'm working sty Dean wood
said well you need a degree and all this
stuff I'm not going to school I'm not
going to get a college degree I said I'm
want to find a way to get a job there
back then when you would fax I fax my
resume to 100 different places Goldman
Merill Smith Barney Morgan every one of
them and I put a joke on my cover letter
and at the bottom of it I said if you
like me this is exactly how my clients
are going to feel doing business with me
they're going to love me if you want
somebody like this part of your team
give me a call I got 30 calls 15 of them
said it was a very unique approach but
your resume sucks haand do B is not
enough for them that's my resume hogen B
Bob's Big Boy and Military that's all I
had I couldn't brag about anything else
and then but 15 others asked me for an
interview three offered me a job Dave
Kirby from the Glendale Branch gave me a
job to be a financial adviser change my
life I started day before 911 910 got my
Series 7 6631 26 life and health and
boom the rest is history this was Dean
Witter Dean Whitter yeah Morgan sley
that's what happened with my dad my dad
didn't finish school he was playing
hockey uh high level hockey stop chasing
a hockey puck around you know and so um
but he wasn't really into it he just
happened to be good at it and he ended
up working at Dean Whitter then EF
Hutton you know both both riddled with
Scandal or really EF Hutton towards the
end of it but he just kind of um he was
good at sale he Charmed his way in and
uh that is something that they value it
used to be very performance-based but
all right I want to so so that makes
sense you had a natural inclination uh
for it and um then you kind of took
sales numbers and people three things I
like sales numbers and people so your
book those choose your enemies wisely we
have have it right there y business
planning for the audacious VI before we
go to mug Club why the book centered
around I know you can pre-order it at
Amazon it's available December 5th
though right December 5th yes why Center
the book around choosing your enemies
wisely so I'll tell you this 45,000
agents you do a lot of business plans
and you watch who makes it and who
doesn't make it okay and you'll watch a
guy that comes in one guy came in from
Northrup you know master's degree
everything proper looked so good but I
could never get him to go and nothing
got him you know to to go compete at the
highest level but logically on paper
everything made sense and then I would
recruit guys that emotionally they
really wanted to win B but logically
they had nothing no substance okay so
then I realized you know when I'm doing
business planning at first I would only
do don't you want a dream don't you want
this and but no plan M and then I
flipped I'm like here's the plan on what
you got to do first quarter and second
quarter and third quarter and all this
other stuff and then I realized you need
to you needed both So eventually it was
two blocks then six blocks then eth
blocks it was 12 build business uh
building blocks to do the proper
business planning but the biggest Factor
biggest Factor was the following I
noticed any of the guys that ever did
anything really really big and I said
this to Tom Brady when I was talking to
at the Vault two months ago one they've
experienced unconditional love from one
person from one person at least this is
a person that no matter what you do
wrong mhm this person is okay with
loving you Mom Mom I'm in jail you're
you're bailing me out but I love you I
can't believe you're here wait a minute
I screwed up this is my fault I'm making
your life help and you still love me
like this damn this is awesome right
this exists unconditional love number
two
is a person you
loved that you really really wanted to
win over that betrayed you and
backstabbed you because no matter what
you do no matter how much money you make
you'll never win them over no matter how
many sixpacks how many houses you buy
how many cars you have how many
subscribers you have you're never going
to get there of you know saying hey good
job you're just not going to get it from
them right so hardcore pain but a lot of
people have those two then you need the
last one and the last one to me is
choosing your enemies wisely uh you know
uh Brady he had his own enemies over his
career Jordan has had his own enemies
musk has the a very unique enemy that's
been driving him for 40 years not just
10 years cuz some enemies drives you for
6 months some it's a month some it's 30
seconds they cut you off you you know
want to get back at them but if you're
able to choose the right enemy it brings
out a side of you that's getting you to
tolerate pain in ways others are not
willing to tolerate that'll help you
compete at the highest level so once I
saw this format and I saw which people
were the ones that were winning at the
highest level and which ones weren't the
ones that typically won had the first
the second and they chose their enemies
wisely and we put the business plan
structure for them and they were on fire
so so you're almost more so picking like
comp do you mean like friendly
competition or do you mean like animus
no not competition is you studying
everybody else you do spreadsheet here's
20 channels that are my industry you
know Jen has 4 million subscribers I'm
at 50,000 my name is Step Crowder this
person's got 2 million that person's got
a million I'm going to kill everybody
right that's competition enemy is
somebody said something to you like you
know sometimes we write affirmations of
good things about us mhm sometimes the
most powerful affirmation is and with
Dana why two days ago in Vegas I'm in
his place and it's crazy I want to read
this from the book I tell him Dana I got
a book coming out at the end of the
meeting he says what's the book called I
said choose your enemies wisely he
starts laughing I said why are you
laughing he says look behind me we're in
his office in Vegas a 30-minute meeting
turns into 2 hours he says look at the
wall I said I can't see the wall he's
got this weird picture and he's got to
explain it to you what it is it's great
he says look at the wall I come around
to look at the wall it's a quote he says
uh make may God have mercy on my enemies
because I won't General Patton yep then
he says that and I said you know you're
quoted in the book he says I'm quoted in
the book I said yeah he says what what
have you quoted me in the book it says
he says when you saiding bet against me
tell me it's not going to happen tell me
it's going to fail I love it I love
every minute of it right this idea of
Dana taking UFC he's given the middle
finger to boxing to people that wanted
to shut it down with Co that drive that
he keeps going and going and going it's
a very unique thing I'll read this uh a
beginning of the book that are kind of
explain this whole concept it says you
have no enemies you say my friend the
boast is poor he who has mingled in The
Fray of Duty that the brave endure must
have made foes if you have none small is
the work that you have
done you've hit no traitor on the hip
you've dashed no cup from pord lip
you've you've never turned the wrong to
right you've been a coward in the fight
Charles McKay okay to me brother when I
read that oh if I tell you stories of
moments where somebody drove me to go to
levels yeah that got the best out of me
sometimes going to go in my office after
you'll see some actually some plaques
that I have in there but but but the
point with that is writing on a piece of
paper not positive things people said to
you and then you just read it mhm and
you start realizing wait a minute this
emotion I'm getting I'm willing to take
the rejection I'm willing to take this
you know late night I got to get my
degree for whatever you work I'm willing
to go through the 6 hours after the kids
are asleep to take that course online to
get my real estate license I'm willing
to pay the price because I'm going to go
out there and do something prove the
people that believed in me right and
prove the people that doubted me wrong
and then eventually my dreams are going
to become a reality yeah yeah that is uh
it is important I used to pick my
enemies poorly just like look at this
dip the tiny umbrella you know and then
you know i' usually like you know hit a
puddle so uh but that was petty and now
I know to pick them
wisely because I pre-ordered the book so
all right it is choose your enemies
wisely business planning for the
audacious few you can pre-order it
Amazon you can go to the website I'm
sure you can follow Patrick f David
anywhere he he does his show I mean
you're obviously not just on YouTube but
I would imagine Spotify Apple all these
places um and we're going to continue
right now on Rumble hey an enemy that
I've picked uh thank you Rumble we're
going to mug Club YouTube piss
[Applause]
[Music]
off